Oh a man walking around like a dog oh
this is horrible
let's break these VFX down yeah there's
a lot of visual effects going on here
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we got some great cook you're gonna be
looking at today a few that we've been
wanting to talk about for a long time
that we're finally addressing you've
been asking for him and we're finally
delivering and there's a very special
clip I have for you guys today it's
called the call of the wild it's about a
man and his dog and a lot of snow I
never saw this film but on NPR I heard a
review everyone just kept saying there's
some love with that dog and I'm like huh
so I decided to look into it mmm okay
yeah you know actually that dog doesn't
look that bad that's pretty pretty
good-looking dog it's a pretty
good-looking pub look at all these dogs
these are all CG dogs so before we even
get into the dogs everything in this
movie is shot like on a blue-screen
stage frightening really like all the
backgrounds you're seeing and all that
stuff they're all on a soundstage right
now okay I can see it's pretty it's
pretty nuts
how much CG is in this film so that
means like if the dogs are CG the ground
they're walking on is CG too because
they're gonna be interacting with the
snow a lot better if it was CG the
concept of CG snow is something that
I've been like paying attention to over
the like it's about the last 10 years
it's something called granular fluid
simulation it's like sand
oh yeah basically but it's like semi
fluid but it clumps in a natural way so
you can see a ton of it in action here
and it's the subtle 100% CG shot that is
nuts dude I mean the dogs look pretty
freakin good it's just too good it's
like they look too good almost there
very expressive but I think that's the
main thing yeah that's what it comes
down to it's like from like a steel
frame they look 100% real like that
looks so good yeah like that right there
looks like a National Geographic photo
of the dog totally but the moment they
start moving they're like magic pups
basically magic props that are ultra
intelligent
and can express themselves in ways that
are just impossible for normal animals
I find myself actually kind of liking
that a lot if this was Air Bud you know
you just have a dog look back not yeah
you get no emotive value out of real
animals like that but here you can see
the determination on his eyes he's like
I'm ready to go this all looks handy and
I made it to me they're like how else
would you do this you know oh it most
definitely probably is him in that case
Clint what do you think the process is
to capture this footage well I mean you
would definitely shoot a number of
plates one without the dog one with
something or someone in the space of the
dog to see how their shadows react to
the environment so you probably you
bring a reference dog to set to
constantly get shots of a real dog in
that area well the producers had a very
different take on this oh boy this is
our dog all the plates of interaction
were done with a man walking around like
a dog do I recognize him he's the planet
of babes eight dude I bet he was so sore
oh my god the amount of yoga you'd have
to do to undo all of that all day long
for months I don't think they're
actually taking any of the motion
capture aspects to it there's an
animator who's watching The Dukes
performance and then making the dog
animate in a similar fashion they're not
actually tracking anything and directly
translating it to the dog tell me though
is it harder to act like a dog on a
motion capture suit or harder for
Harrison Ford to act like this man in
front of you as a dog I think it's easy
enough to believe that you are a dog
when you're in that situation I think
it's harder for a person like Harrison
Ford to embrace the fact that this is
not a person and it's a dog I'll just
tell you like if I do this this is hard
for me to imagine here a dog this is
like good
we're gonna replace him with a dog later
Harrison Ford is probably not thinking I
have to imagine he's a dog he's probably
just thinking like the way I'm actually
reacting to this guy in a mocap suit is
probably the same way I'd be reacting to
a dog right now a certain actor might do
it a different way but I think they all
try to get to an end goal by a bunch of
different means I think Harrison Ford is
probably just like what I'm just a
little strange I'm rolling around on the
floor with this guy scratching his tummy
cuz they had to I guess right there's
money involved
they're leaning into these animals
having performances so it makes sense to
have a person inspiring those
performances I would make an argument
that this is one of those films that
they need to release an alternate cut of
they should release the the man cut of
this one where we see the actual motion
capture actor performing the dog's
actions look the Mahina scenes seeing
the dog man
is a goof but I think there's some
really good execution still going on
here there are moments where it's like
obviously not a real dog but it doesn't
detract from the experience of watching
it oh I think watching the full movie
might change your mind biting me me dude
you know this reminds me is hocus-pocus
the cat ain't hocus-pocus
it's hallowed ground witches can't set
foot here he talks I mean he was a
puppet right it was a CG mouth moving
and stuff I think it was a puppet mouth
I think I'm pretty sure of CG couldn't
have been a CG cat this movie came out
in the early 90s why it's so impressive
it came out before Jurassic Park there's
no way that was a CG cat you're gonna to
pretty sure I'm pretty pretentious up
now because of me my little sister's
life for stolen you know see look at
that real cat with a CG face that's what
that is not a CG face appreciate
computer-generated Clint I'm telling you
there's no possible way it was a CG cat
I'm gonna get you my phone or no okay
Rhythm & Hues the visual effects and
animation company that created CGI went
all-out making his feline features
realistic
reduce the performance of the mouth was
matching the performance of the eyes so
I will give you that Clint hey if you
guys are enjoying this video and are not
subscribed please consider subscribing
because we put one out every single week
and they're all really fun I promise so
this is the mermaid alright this is
directed by Stephen Chow he's one of my
all-time favorite directors I think it's
really a really weird movie it's got
some funny jokes some funny scenes but
it's weird alright just brace yourself
it's weird
alright this guy is trying to kill that
main bad guy over here an assassin is so
the guy in the black jacket is bad guy
yes what's wrong with his pants
something's up okay oh he's split man
he's an octopus by the way yeah I can
tell and that that's the bad guys
bodyguards they're hunting down all
these like fish people so he's trying to
play it cool or else he's gonna he's
gonna die here you're the chef right so
cook the food oh this is horrible
they're funny they're cutting up his
tentacles and cooking him a lie oh this
is oh this is horrible oh my god agony
oh my god
this is so twisted look at this exit
though
he's like just the practical like
octopus ball man window like just the
concept of the scene is so gross let's
break these VFX them yeah there's a lot
of visual effects going on yeah okay
those tentacles look pretty solid but
you could tell they're so CG oh yeah all
right but they will tell yourselves look
fine it's the comping into the real
footage that is suffering a little bit
yeah but you can tell this got fake
shadows underneath him yeah
contact shadows are a little kind of
janky here yeah it's weird it's like not
bad but you can still tell that it's
pretty obviously the effects this
reminds me of some of the stuff that
we've made because it's like the visual
effects are good enough to convey a
point but not like Hollywood grade like
grade-a effects but this is a
non-serious scene the dudes frying
himself and he's even the reaction yeah
yeah that octopus clip is really jacked
up and if you have any other jacked up
visual effects clips that you would like
to see us break down let us know in the
comments below
okay so 1917 a movie about world war 1
but not just about the war but about the
people who fought in the war it's it's
famously a single take movie the entire
movie was filmed in one shot one shot
obviously that's impossible you can't
shoot this whole thing in one shot so
you gotta fake it what visual effects
so there there are easy ways to mask
transitions if you have just something
cross frame that's a classic really easy
way to do it and that is in this movie
all over the place it's really easy to
identify but there's a few times where
it's right in front of your face and you
don't realize it but let's say they
shoot one take of these guys like
crawling up and over a mound but they
have to cut to a different take where
they're looking at kind of the same
camera angle but there's no way to wipe
between them now you have to like
somehow combine these two entirely
different shots together in front of
your eyes the whole time like a card
trick do this whole sequence crossing
no-man's land was oh my god not like the
the corpses sticking out of mud
and that was it that was it that was a
transition yeah so they did a CG double
oh I see what you're saying to morph
between the two different shots this is
a scene where we have characters
starting at Point a at the end of one
shot and they begin at point B in the
next shot and in order to transition
between them they basically transition
to a completely CG character to complete
that movement from one location to the
next but it's invisible because they're
so good it's a lot of like projecting
the the ground and the crater on system
geometry and just kind of like morphing
it into place so that ideally it looks
exactly like the beginning of the next
shot so they could just cut the CG stuff
out and resume the real footage
afterward that that's cool I've never
seen a CG transition like that I'm sure
they've done this before but like this
type of use of it is really it's it's
really advanced it's definitely hard to
do and there's lots of scenes in this
movie that are like them see like right
there that was did you see it
they cut to a digi double there as he
drove in now we don't have
behind-the-scenes footage of this but I
think we can tell we're like he goes and
he goes through the actions of actually
jumping and then they they they're done
shooting for the day they start up the
next day with him jumping down into the
crater and now they have to morph those
two shots together with just a photo
real digi double and they just match his
his posture perfectly go through the
motion to match the posture of him in
the next moment those are the types of
things you probably are not gonna notice
when you're watching this film it it won
the Oscar for Best Visual Effects this
year because you never notice any visual
effects in this movie they're everywhere
and yet never once think about the
visual effects
World War 1 really jacked up if you
don't know a lot about World War one and
you're interested Dan Carlin has an
amazing World War one podcast called
blueprint for Armageddon you you should
you should listen to it because it will
give you a really really good
perspective on how the 20th century kind
of kicked off 1917 is a fantastic movie
if you haven't watched it you better go
do it and also watch hocus pocus it's a
good hey guys thank you so much for
watching this episode I had a blast Ren
had a blast Sam had a good time too
you know it's great that we can all get
together and break down these VFX shots
for you guys so please keep watching
keep subscribing keep commenting send us
your VFX shots we love doing this see
you guys on the next one hey that's
pretty good
hey that is pretty good that's pretty
good hey that was pretty good
good good